[Music]
I thought I'd make uh a big Life
Update some of you have noticed I
haven't posted any videos in some years
and I'm starting to post again and so
here's what's been up uh 2016 I was here
in Vancouver doing a lot of um Fusion
partner dancing and Acro yoga um but I'd
lost my motivation with po and I was
starting to feel like an impostor then I
got some injuries a big heartbreak got
depressed and decided I would go on a
world photography tour because I was
inspired with that good connections with
people beautiful places but I thought it
would help Market my online courses uh
and it didn't and it just cost me
thousands and thousands and thousands of
dollars um but being an artist I I dealt
with that in a mature and sophisticated
way
[Music]
um and then ended up in Costa Rica um
helping to save and raise baby monkeys
and paddle board surfing and that's a
great flow art and then covid hit and I
ended up back in Canada decided what am
I doing with my life went back to
University to finish a degree that I
started in 1995 um that was cool getting
my brain flowing and then around just
after I graduated um I went to vo's
workshops here in Vancouver met some
cool people they do Po and they also do
Brazilian zuk dancing and uh and I love
Brazilian zuk it is so flowy and sensual
and sexy and it really got me thinking
about how I want to move finding ways
that I like
moving and I started picking up my POI
more often and I started thinking can I
integrate that the P you know I always
wanted to be able to do really
consistent spins with good arm lines um
because those deteriorated so I've been
feeling motivated I started thinking
maybe I'll make videos and see who wants
to master spins with me who wants to
tighten up their lines and their
expression with me and I've come out of
retirement uh my online courses have
continued to sell all these years and
some of that's because I put so much
work to them I'm proud of them a lot of
it's because so many of you have help
have spread the word I know you've been
telling people and I've like countless
people to thank who I'll never even know
who you are so I've put the PO
fundamentals the learn and master the
fundamentals of poi Series in my
membership section right here in YouTube
I have ideas po challenges where I'll be
posting about spins and extensions and
dance uh and that's it I feel really I
feel good I also found some really good
therapy so we'll see I think I'm rolling
time will tell reporting from Vancouver
inspired Nick Wy unretired
[Music]